y rusia sea el tercer exportador de
petróleo en el mundo y el segundo de gas
natural aislamiento del mercado
internacional puede beneficiar a países
latinos que son productores de
combustible como colombia y venezuela o
por el contrario se puede esperar que
suban los precios de la energía en la
región
los precios de la energía van a subir
evidentemente colombia-venezuela
trinidad el ecuador guyana se van a
beneficiar países como brasil como la
argentina van a sufrir
debido a que son importadores de
petróleo o sea en promedio en la región
va a salir más o menos bien por otro
lado hay aumentos de precios de
alimentos que le le beneficia a brasil y
argentina uruguay y le perjudica a otros
países pero digamos la región de todas
maneras va a tener un golpe
relativamente suave en términos de estos
presos y hablemos concretamente de un
país que usted mencionó brasil porque el
presidente de jair bolsonaro ha dicho
que no quiere sancionar a rusia porque
esto afectaría a la agricultura del
gigante sudamericano es esto posible
y yo creo que
puede tratar de escapar lo pero
evidentemente
brasil es un gran exportador de soja
no solamente a rusia sino que también a
china y por eso él está diciendo una
cosa así sin embargo yo creo que van a
ver presiones muy muy importantes para
qué
tomé sanciones en contra de brasil en
contra de rusia no puedo decirlo con
certeza pero de todas maneras los
precios de las de estos productos han
ido aumentando la brasil se beneficia
puede jugar con eso y si bien usted nos
dice que puede no sentirse muchas
consecuencias en américa latina por las
sanciones contra rusia que podría pasar
en la región
bueno yo creo que en la parte de precios
algunos países ganan a algunos países
pierden yo creo que el problema más
serio es el siguiente aquellas ventas
que se hacen a rusia o que sea nuestro a
rusia quedan sin pagar cuando no está el
sistema swift de pago en los bancos cómo
van a pagarle los rusos a los
latinoamericanos sería muy muy difícil
porque no tienen un buen sistema que le
compense y no van a considerar a américa
latina una gran prioridad y en ese
sentido yo creo que va a ser una
situación muy muy difícil no es que
rusia sea demasiado importante en el
comercio internacional de américa latina
pero evidentemente esta parte de los
pagos va a afectar directamente
a américa latina